a teenage girl who police say ran off to
Mexico with a 45 year old man is back in
her Pennsylvania hometown this morning
Kevin Esterly was arrested and is now
being held in Miami he's charged with
child custody interference after being
found with 16 year-old Amy you and
Mexico on Saturday police say the two
were in a relationship
mega Oliver is in Allentown with the
breakthrough in the investigation Meg
good morning
beyond a good morning a me you was taken
to this hospital yesterday after she
returned from Mexico she apparently was
unharmed Yu's mother told me she was so
relieved when they found her she started
crying
Mexican police and US federal agents
found Kevin Esther Lee and Amy you
hiding out in Playa del Carmen the
Mexican resort town is more than
15-hundred miles from Allentown Police
Captain William Lake all information
received thus far leaves investigators
to believe that a me you left Allentown
willingly with Kevin Esther Lee the pair
vanished March 5th with their passports
and more than $10,000 that night police
say they flew from Philadelphia to
Dallas and then Cancun on one-way plane
tickets frank castro vinci says he was a
passenger on one of their flights out of
Philadelphia International Airport at
first he thought you was Esther Lee's
daughter but then I saw her leaning on
him
yeah which daughters do but just the way
he was rubbing her leg it just did not
seem like a father-daughter situation a
married father of four Esther Lee
befriended Amy's family through church
[Music]
you became close friends with Esther
Lee's daughter and often went on their
family vacations in February Amy's
mother discovered her daughter had
listed Esther Lee as her stepfather on
school records police say he checked her
out of school ten times without her
mother's permission
amy is 16 the legal age of consent in
Pennsylvania
her mother moyu told us last week she
also found text messages suggesting
Esther Lee was romantically involved
with her daughter Lou who did not want
to appear on camera said she felt
betrayed you had Kevin over to your
house yeah then for her meals if a meal
for bat paisa and me putting a lawyer
for Esther Lee's wife Stacy told CBS
this morning stacy is happy that amy is
home and that Kevin is in custody
he also said Esther Lee has been calling
Stacy from jail but she has not accepted
his calls John meg thanks